deutschland hat wieder einen
problembären und dass das sind die
ersten fotos exklusive bilder das größte
problem an diesem problem werden der ort
an dem ihr jetzt auftaucht ja der ort an
dem er schafe reisst und der ort an dem
sich schon in wenigen tagen die
mächtigsten männer der welt treffen in
bayern und dieser ort der hat eben jetzt
ein problembären einen g7 problem werden
sie sind die mächtigsten männer der welt
die g7 und er kommt ihnen ganz nahe zu
nahe
nachtaufnahmen von unserem bild
reportern der braunbär von ellmau ein
problembär der g7 wer denn hier wo er
neuerdings durch die wälder schleicht er
treffen sie sich die wichtigsten und
mächtigsten regierungschefs der welt am
wochenende geht es los g7 gipfel in
ellmau alles abgeriegelt überall polizei
maximale sicherheitsstufe doch er hält
sich an all das nicht der g7 der
schafzüchter christian noyer ist
verzweifelt es ist ungewöhnlich dass ein
bär so viele so viele in seiner art und
weise tötet
trocken entsetzt dass wir die bilder
gesehen habe also einen tierfreund wenn
du das herz weh wenn man sowas ist doch
wo kommt der g7 wer plötzlich her so
kurz bevor die ganze welt auf erblickt
eingewandert aus der norditalienischen
provinz trient jetzt gefährlich nahe an
bayern ein halber tages marshall meister
thomas frank in andere länder finnland
schweden oder irgendwo wo die tiere wo
die immer schon gibt
besteht durchaus gefahr für menschen
der g7 problem wer sofort werden
erinnerungen wach an 2006 als ganz
deutschland über den problembären von
bayern diskutierte dann haben wir normal
verhalten er lebt im wald geht niemals
aus
und reißt vielleicht ein bis zwei schafe
ihn ja
wir haben dann einen unterschied
zwischen dem normalen sich falten
erdbeer und dem problembär da gibt es
nur die lösungen zu beseitigen weil
einfach die gefahr so groß ist jetzt
wieder ein problembär der g7 wer von
ellmau er schleicht weiter durch den
wald nur wenige kilometer fußmarsch ist
zu den mächtigsten männern der welt
ja dem problembär auf der spur ist unser
reporter jörg völkerling nämlich eben
gerade auch im beitrag gesehen jörg wie
gestaltet sich jetzt die suche nach dem
problem der der muss ja irgendwie noch
vor dem wochenende empfunden werden
[Applaus]
das ist quasi unmöglich den zu finden
diese bergwelt die ist so zerklüftet und
das sind ja auch die aufforderung vor
denen die 18.000 polizisten stehen die
diesen gipfel jetzt absichern müssen mit
drei meter hohen zeugen wobei jeder
natürlich weiß dass solche zäune keinen
schutz vor dem bären bieten also 2006
habe es in dem beitrag gesehen hier gab
es den problembären 2022 hat bayern ein
bären management man will also quasi
jetzt einen bären monitoring betreiben
so heißt das vollmundig vom landesamt
für umwelt und erst mal schauen wo es
bären sich umgab und da gab es einige in
den letzten wochen monaten in ohlstadt
fahrig hand und dann jetzt eben zuletzt
der bären riss ende mai in scharnitz auf
österreichischer seite 16 schafe
gerissen wurden per dienen als auch
nachgewiesen wurden es war ein
männlicher bär und scharnitz diese der
alpen wir können das hier mal sehen dass
es
ein gebiet was quasi das aufzeichnen was
gewesen ist und überall sind hier b
heißt es hier bären steigt apple ipad
satte also es ist historisch ein
belastetes gebiet vor hunderten jahren
waren hier viele viele bären heute ist
das ein touristisch hoch belastetes
gebiet und die einbauen mit denen wir
gesprochen haben sagen sie können hier
keine beutegreifer gebrauchen so lange
der sich schäfer hält mag das noch
angehen aber wir hatten eben das
beispiel von bär bruno der problembär
2006 der auf höfe gegangen ist der
honig geraubt hat von imkern den
menschen gefährlich nahe gekommen ist so
dass am ende sogar jäger aus finnland
eingeflogen werden mussten die ihnen
dann abschließen sollten und tatsächlich
hat er dieses schicksal dann auch litten
aber gerade das macht das ganze so hoch
politisch die ganze geschichte die jäger
haben damals motoren bekommen es hoch
unpopulär ein so seltenes tier wie den
bären abzuschießen aber die almbauern
60.000 scharf sind da in dieser region
sagen es gibt gar keinen anderen weg sie
mit dieser bär muss abgeschossen werden
und sie sagen inzwischen sogar es ist
nicht nur ein bär dort unterwegs und es
könnten mehrere sein der förster in
diesem karwendel teil der wand die
touristen schon davor dieses gebiet noch
zu betreten wohingegen die tiroler
landesregierung sagt das gehe keine
gefahr von menschen aus aber schon
angekündigt hat dass werden in dieser
saison keine schafe mehr auf die alm
getrieben also offen vor der kamera will
das keiner sagen aber es ist schon
brisante situation also die schafe
bleiben schon mal drin vor diesem
g7-gipfel aus angst vor diesem neuen
problembären du hast gerade erinnert an
2006 an den problembären bruno der dann
geschossen wurde und du hast gerade
nochmal gesagt von jägern aus finnland
bringen uns nochmal rechtlich auf den
stand also wenn er jetzt sozusagen
dieser neue g7 problembär vor die flinte
laufen würde dürfte man den schießen
jetzt so knapp vor dem g7 gipfel
also ich denke rechtlich wäre das
durchaus möglich und es sind ja auch
genug polizisten da die entsprechend
reagieren könnten wir haben erst gestern
die nachrichten gesehen von einem
anderen fall wo ein bär auf ein mann
losgegangen ist und dann selber auch
getötet wurde also es gibt die
möglichkeit aber das ist einfach hoch
unpopulär es gibt kaum jäger die die
dafür wirklich den kopf erhalten wollen
weil sie wissen dass sie dann in der
bevölkerung der öffentlichkeit auch
schief angesehen werden also viele
verniedlichen dieses problem noch und
sagen das ist eine ja das ist doch schön
wenn wieder sozusagen die natur sich
raum greift aber diese schafe gerade in
der region sind einfach ein bestandteil
der der weidewirtschaft der natur
erhaltung und wenn es zu solchen fällen
kommt wie diese grausamen bilder von den
schafen deren wirklich den sind einfach
im blutrausch die bäuche aufgerissen
wurden dass die organe raus gequollen
sind noch nicht mal aus zum zur
ernährung des bären sondern aus reinem
jagdtrieb da kann man natürlich dann
auch die alm bewirtschafter die schäfer
verstehen dass sie sagen der muss weg
der muss abgeschossen werden ihre
geschichte die uns unser bild reporter
jörg völker legen aus bayern mitbringen
danke dir jörg und wir sehen diesem
problem werden gerade noch weil ihnen
die augen dass sind exklusive bilder
dort aus der nacht also schauen wir noch
mal drauf auf diese nachtaufnahmen hier
das ist er der neue problembär über den
deutsch entspricht der reißt schafe und
das größte problem an diesem neuen
problembären ist das eher ein g7 bär ist
nämlich dort auftaucht wo in wenigen
tagen die mächtigsten männer der welt
sich treffen werden in elm europa
garmisch partenkirchen in bayern
ausgerechnet dort hat deutschland jetzt
in diesem sommer einen neuen
problembären